welcome to the presentation on dividing
fractions let's get started so before i
give you the intuition actually i might
do that in a in a different module i'm
just going to show you the mechanics of
how you divide a fraction
and and it turns out that it's actually
not much more difficult than multiplying
fractions if i were to ask you one-half
divided by one-half
whenever you divide by
a fraction or actually when you divide
by any number it's the same thing as
multiplying by its inverse so one-half
divided by one-half is equal to one-half
times
two over one
we just inverted
inverse
the second one-half
and we know from the multiplication
module one-half times two over one well
that's just equal to two over two
or it's equal to one
and that makes sense because actually
any number divided by itself is equal to
one one-half divided by one-half is one
just like five divided by five is one
just like 100 divided by 100 is one and
this this isn't a new principle actually
you you are always doing it think about
it this way
what is
two
uh divided by two well you know that's
one but isn't this also the same thing
as two times the inverse of two
which is one
i'll show it to you actually let me let
me give you a couple more examples to
show that this dividing fraction
really isn't the new concept this this
whole notion of multiplying by the
inverse
if i were to tell you what is
12
divided by 4. well we know the answer to
this but i'm going to show you that this
is the same thing as
12
times
1 4.
12 over 1 times 1 over 4 is 12 over 4
which is 3. and 1204 is really just
another way of writing 12 divided by 4.
so
kind of a long way of getting to the
same point but i just wanted to show you
that what we're what we're doing in this
module is is nothing new than what we've
always been doing when we divide by a
number division is is the same thing
dividing by a number is the same thing
as multiplying by the inverse of that
number and just as a review and inverse
if i have a number
a
the inverse
inverse in short for inverse is one over
a
so
um the inverse of two-thirds
is three-halves or the inverse of
because 5 is the same thing as 5 over 1
so the inverse is 1 over 5. we're just
flipping it we're switching the
numerator and denominator
so let's do some
fraction division problems
what is
two
thirds
divided by
five over six
well we know this is the same thing as
two thirds
times
six over five
and that's equal to twelve over fifteen
you could divide the numerator and
denominator by three that's four over
five
what is
seven over eight
divided by
one fourth
well that's the same thing as
seven
over eight
times
four over one
remember i just flip this 1 4. divide by
1 4 is the same thing as multiplying by
4 over 1. that's all you got to do and
then we could use a little shortcut we
learned in the multiplication model
module 8 divided by 4 is 2. 4 divided by
4 is 1. so that equals 7 over 2.
or if you wanted to write that as a
mixed number this is of course an
improper fraction improper fractions
have a numerator larger than the
denominator if you wanted to write that
as a mixed number
2 goes into 7 three times with a
remainder of one so that's three and a
half
you can write either way i tend to keep
it this way because it's easier to deal
with
let's do a ton of more problems or at
least as many as we can do in the next
four or five minutes
what's negative
two-thirds
divided by
uh
five
halves
once again
if that's the same thing as minus
two-thirds whoops as minus two over
three
times what
it's times the inverse of five over two
which is
two over five
and that equals
minus 4
over 15.
what is
3 halves divided by 1 6
well
that's just the same thing as 3 halves
times
six over one
which equals
three and a one we just divide the six
by two and the two by two
so that equals
nine
think you might be getting it now let's
see let's do a couple more and then of
course you can always pause and and look
at the this whole presentation again so
you can get confused all over again
let's see let's do
minus 5 over seven
divided by
ten over three well this is the same
thing as minus five over seven
times
three over ten
i just multiplied by the inverse that's
all i keep doing over and over again
minus 5 times 3
minus 15
7 times
10
is 70.
if we divide the numerator and the
denominator by 5 we get minus 3
over 14.
we could have also just done it here we
could have done 5
2 and we've got minus 3 over 14 as well
let's do
one or two more problems
i think you kind of get it though
let's say
one half
divided by
minus three aha so what happens when you
take a fraction you divided by a whole
number or an integer well we know any
whole number can be written as a
fraction
this is the same thing as one-half
divided by
minus three over one
and dividing by a fraction is the same
thing as multiplying
by its numerator it's inverse
so the inverse of 3 negative 3 over 1 is
negative 1 over 3
and this equals negative 1 6.
let's do it the other way what if i had
negative 3
divided by
1 half same thing negative 3 is the same
thing as minus
minus 3 minus 3 over 1 divided by 1 half
which is the same thing as minus 3 over
1 times
2
over 1 which is equal to minus
6 over 1 which equals minus 6.
now let me give you a little bit of
intuition of why this works
let's say i said 2
divided by
1 3. well we know that this is equal to
2 over 1 times 3 over 1 which equals 6.
so how does 2 1 3 and 6 relate well
let's look at this way if i had two
pieces of pizza
i have two pieces of pizza here's my two
pieces of pizza
right two right here so i have two
pieces of pizza and i'm gonna divide
them
into thirds
so i'm gonna divide each pizza into a
third i'll draw a little mercedes sign
so i'm dividing each pizza into a third
right
how many pieces do i have let's see one
two three
four
five
six i have six pizzas so you might wanna
sit and and ponder that for a little bit
but i think it it might make a little
bit of uh
of sense to you
i always do one more just to
just to tire your brain
if i had negative
7 over 2 divided by
4 9
let's make it negative 4 9. well that's
the same thing as
minus 7 over 2
times minus 9
over 4 right i just multiplied by the
inverse of negative 4 9.
9 times 7 is equal to negative and 7
times negative 9 is positive 63
and 2 times 4 is 8.
hopefully i think you have a good idea
of how to divide by a fraction now and
you can you can try out
the the dividing fractions modules have
fun